falls ihr euch fragt was das Ding hier
oben auf meinem Kopf ist
dann habe ich die Antwort für euch
zudem oder fragen was das
hier für plüsching ist ein neues Dreieck
Euro Mikrofon ich habe mir für 30 €
extra übrigens auch noch so ein Pelz
dafür gekauft also wenn ich jetzt Puste
hört sich das gut an
Freunde nicht um mein neues Mikrofon
geben oder um diese VR Brille sondern um
den Shop Simulator
oh hi
kann ich Musik anmachen irgendwas
jetzt auch naja okay wir fangen an zu
kochen jetzt COOKING CHEF human machen
die kleine guck mal warte ich stell dich
mal vor
warum treffe ich immer diesen Idioten
Mann geh aus dem weg ich will liebe
Freundin klären
die aus dem Weg
wer gefragt hat danke leute wir jetzt
hier Bacon unten Spiegelei braten müssen
würde ich sagen machen wir unseren
Schrank erstmal zu und ersetzen das
Ganze durch unseren Kühlschrank wo wir
erstmal haben sehr gut nehmen wir
erstmal raus
und hier unten haben wir wahrscheinlich
drin hallo
[Musik]
20.000 387 Stunden später
gerade mit dem Kollegen telefoniert
der Orthopäde ist gut danke er hat
gesagt Zitat
Luca stell dich nicht so an und mach
deinen Job
machen wir jetzt auch wir sind wieder
beim Job Simulator angekommen von daher
haben wir tatsächlich noch immer die
gleiche Aufgabe und unser
ja doch das geht noch unser ganz
vorsichtig auf dem Teller ich habe
wieder Schiss dass ich hier irgendwo
Gegenschlag ich muss mal ganz kurz oh
mein Gott
erstmal Musik glaube ich ein bisschen zu
chillen so schreibe hier rein zack zu
mit dem Ding
ist 700 € habe ich insgesamt ins Headset
und die Mikrofon Konstruktion gesteckt
und es regt mich einfach nur auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nee mein Spieler ist und am Toaster
Bacon und Spiegelei kommt sofort Madame
miss you erstmal das Ding auf
ab jetzt tun wir so als wäre es unser
erster Arbeit oh Fische wir nehmen hier
ein Bacon raus klatschen den drauf
machen aber auch nicht allzu heiße
Hälfte machen natürlich auch den
Kühlschrank wieder zu ne Energie sparen
zack ein Ei rausnehmen äh
m
wir nehmen einen neuen Bacon raus packen
oh nein
also neue Spiegel wieder rausnehmen
ist noch nicht ganz fertig wir müssen
jetzt beides nur im Auge behalten der
Bacon
es gibt gefühlt nur eine Stufe normal
und verbrannt das sieht gut aus so zack
essen ist fertig
[Musik]
viel schnell wir haben eine nächste
Aufgabe und zwar
verarscht ich würde sagen wir wollen
erstmal ein bisschen auf das Spiegelei
kommt in Müll das Steak kommt in Müll
und hier die Eierschalen schmeißen wir
auch mal weg zack wir können jetzt hier
umstellen auf Mixer dann haben wir hier
nämlich das ganze umgefahren und nichts
sagen
was gehört denn in einen guten Smoothie
auf jeden Fall eine Tomate
die ist gut Karotten nehmen wir mal auf
Zack
wir nehmen einen Apfel reinpacken und
das sind keine Smoothie fehlender ist
Steak
let's go
ja die Katze habe ich leider alle schon
weggeschmissen
hier achso dafür ist das Ding ach so
guck mal voll Smoothie wer will
guten Appetit wir sind für dich nur
human beverage
Arschloch ich Hunger mache ich mir
erstmal einen schönen Spiegelei was ich
mir jetzt schön reinpfeife für mich
passt das so schon
ausgemacht und da ich den Teebeutel
leider weggeschmissen habe
nehmen wir natürlich unseren denn wir
haben ja auch Tee
ach so wir können anders vorgehen wir
machen erstmal hier auf singen und
füllen jetzt in die Karaffe Wasser rein
so schaut mal her sag Wasser wieder aus
Karaffe hier von Hamm war ab hier drauf
auf dem Grill das ganze erhitzen so dass
das Wasser sprudelt ach guck mal das ist
ja total easy wenn man hier auf die
Leute hört vielleicht sollte man doch
nicht einfach so kamikazemäßig alleine
Vorgehen also hier einfach abwarten ist
das Ganze grün ist perfekt drüber Grill
aus
Amerika
Beutel da
erstmal gute Laune
[Musik]
jetzt kommt mein Part
Arschgesicht
[Musik]
ja Freunde ich bin ganz ehrlich ich weiß
nicht wie ich das ganze jetzt
abschließen soll wir können doch mal
alles durch gucken das hier sind halt
nur so Geräte die haben
Mixer halt dementsprechend ist eine
Spüle und eine Mikrowelle hier haben wir
nur den Grill und Pott
hallo ich will es wirklich sagen aber
wir haben reingeschissen bei einem Spiel
ab 0
für 9 Euro wo man kochen muss
das war Virtual Reality mit Luca wenn es
euch gefallen hat
dann
habt ihr echt ziemlich beschissen